so we are continuing this morning
looking at the normal distribution
probably I should have added on and
maybe you want to add on if you haven't
written your title yet specifically what
we're gonna look at is characteristics
of the normal distribution we've sort of
seen the shape it comes up all the time
which is why it is called the normal
distribution but we're gonna learn a
little bit more about it and we're gonna
get a little bit technical which is why
you've got your formula sheets there
I'll get to that in a second so at the
moment we have we know two
characteristics about the normal
distribution and they're right there in
in your face when you just look at what
the graph looks like can someone give me
one of the characteristics yeah okay so
clearly you can see it's symmetrical
there's no positive positive or negative
skew okay so it's right smack bang down
the middle it's a bell curve shape so
that's the first thing that we noticed
what was the other thing that we
mentioned it had to do with measures of
locations remember that it has to do
with the mean and the mode and the
median what do we notice about that on
the normal distribution they're all
exactly the same number and you find
them right here in the middle so the
first thing I'd like you to put onto
here I've added on some um helpful lines
down the bottom is if you draw a line up
from the center if I've done a
reasonable job what you should find is
it will line up exactly with the top of
the bell curve so down the bottom here
you move this over
precise there we go down the bottom here
I'd like us to label that as the mean so
I'm gonna put that as X Bob like that
now what you can see is I've put a whole
bunch of other markers there and what
each one represents is a standard
deviation so we know you can take a set
of data and you can punch all the
numbers into your calculator and then it
spits out if you ask it to the standard
deviation which is a measure of not
location but spread remember that so
each one of these markers on the side
here is one of those standard deviations
so if the standard deviation on your set
of scores was like five across a test
out of 100% okay then if this is 50% and
this would be 55 and this would be 45
does that make sense that we've gone one
one standard deviation either way okay
now here's where your colors are gonna
come in if we say I'll zoom in a little
bit here on either side I've got the
mean plus once their deviation so I'm
gonna write that as X bar plus you might
remember the symbol for standard
deviation sometimes people use an S for
standard deviation about the more common
symbol and a little more specific is
this weird Greek letter here with an M
on the sign if you add once their
deviation you go to the right if you
subtract one standard deviation you go
to the left now you can see definitely
and I'm gonna ask you to draw a couple
of vertical lines here just like we did
before as you can see the lion's share
of people in this population are between
these two markers right so if you go
plus one standard deviation - most
ambition all the people in between look
how much of the population that is right
a huge
proportion of people are in there so
let's actually if you've got some colors
there maybe a highlighter or something
like that I'm going to shade that in
sorry mine's a bit messy but you'll get
the idea okay so the way I would
describe this group of people that I've
shaded in here is that they are within
one standard deviation of the mean
that's a really important phrase so I'd
actually like you I've given you some
space on the right hand side so we'll
write this all in this group of people
I've shaded in the middle they are
within one standard deviation of the
mean they may be above they may be below
but in terms of distance they're within
that range yeah say that again this is
not the same as what sorry oh great
question that's right it's very
different we're talking not about
quartiles but about standard deviations
which is much more fine and precise okay
so that's a good question so this is not
about upper or lower quartiles this is
about our standard deviations okay so I
actually missed a bit off the end there
it's within one standard deviation of
the mean
now I said I'm clearly just by looking
at the graph this is most of the people
in the population because normal
distributions happen so frequently in
nature and in populations this one
standard deviation amount has actually
been very highly studied and so we know
in a normal population and the standard
deviation calculation gives you
specifically and I'm going to put it in
right in the middle here let me let me
draw over it it gives you approximately
68% of the population you will find
within one standard deviation of the
mean and you can see that on the just by
looking at the shape of it 68% it's
about bad 70 right so you're getting
about 30% on either side who are outside
of that standard deviation who were that
far away from the average okay okay so
that number 68% is really important to
come back to it in a minute now once you
come to the next graph okay we've been
one standard deviation yet most people
but if you go further if you go a second
standard deviation away so again let's
mark in the mean it's right there in the
middle I'm gonna go not just one marker
out but two markers are so you can see
this marker over here whoops yeah that
smells like is the average plus two
standard deviations so that's two times
this little weak area here okay if you
draw it your line from there
and you make one on the opposite side
two standard deviations below the mean
that's gonna be over here - okay
does that make sense to your following
okay so let's highlight this now and you
can see because we've gone because we've
gone further you're getting a much
larger proportion of the population so
how would we work this sum this
population now over here that I've
shaded well you're not within one
standard deviation of the mean anymore
you're within two standard deviations of
the mean and that's how you'd word it so
as you're as you're colouring in because
you're getting more over again this
pattern this calculations been well
researched what we find is that you get
within two standard deviations of the
mean approximately 95% of the population
okay - these two standard deviations
above or below the mean is quite
exceptional right so if you are that far
away that means you're within a 5
percent bracket of the population
because you're quite extraordinary in
one direction or the other okay all
right so I gave you three standard apps
rather three normal distributions what
do you think we're gonna put on the last
one
with you three okay so again the most
important thing is you put the mean on
there so put X bar right there in the
middle and this time we're going to go
three so that's the last marker I
believe that I've given you obviously so
by now you're sort of starting to get
there it takes longer to color because
you're coloring more of the population
which leads me to my last question which
is how much of the population so we went
68 percent
then we got ninety five percent three
standard deviations is really far away
from the mean you have to be really
quite an amazing person one way or the
other so what you get if you're three
standard deviations away is well that's
not the size I wanted is approximately
99.7% of the population now those
numbers those numbers really matter
which is why I've given you the formula
data sheet because if you have a look at
the first page of the formula data sheet
the one that we have introduced its full
a form I want you to have a look at the
bottom right hand corner and you will
see this piece of information about the
normal distribution there are the dot
points right do you see I'll just load
it up over here
can you guys read it there do you see it
above my head behind your head okay
you've got approximately 68 percent who
have Zen scores what is in school other
what's the relevance of Zen school I
haven't said dead score at all until now
that is how many standard deviations you
are your score is above or below the
mean does that make sense
so Zen score of negative 1 would mean
you are one standard deviation below
right zedd score of positive 1 means
your once then deviation above so if you
have a Zed score say 0.5 you're in that
range of 68% if you've got a Zed score
of negative 1.2 you've gone outside the
first bracket now you're in the second
bracket so you're within 95% and then so
on okay so those numbers are important
it's handy to recognize them but in case
you have trouble remembering than they
are they are here I'll also point out
just while you've got the formula sheet
in there you also recognize the formulas
for outliers there to see those do you
recognize the 1 and 1/2 interquartile
range that's there so again this is not
about memory it's about being able to
read this and understand what does it
mean when you're going lower quartile
minus that much or the upper quartile
plus that much okay